bref ici sur mime je suis ici pour vous
proposer une expérience autour de ma
musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon attends
[Rires]
une étoile ou un petit cœur je sais pas
en fait parce que sur Instagram
[Applaudissements]
indépendamment je trouve la photo
esthétiquement plutôt réussi et je
trouve les courbes sympathiques et voilà
Van Gogh derrière
alors c'est pas du tout un Van Gogh
alors oui mais c'est inquiétant quand
même parce que ça rappelle ce qu'elle
avait fait en 2007 c'était rasé les
cheveux et au moment où elle avait une
grande dépression et là elle est sortie
de la tutelle de son père mais on a
l'impression qu'elle est en plein
désordre émotionnel elle recommence à
faire n'importe quoi et franchement ça
fait peur elle voit plus ces deux
enfants alors
elle est même pas je crois qu'elle est
même pas c'est depuis qu'on a voulu
traumatisée par la tutelle et d'ailleurs
sa mère a fait des excuses publiques
cette semaine et parce qu'elle voit plus
ses parents et donc elle voit plus non
plus ses enfants et donc ça sa maman lui
a fait des excuses publiques dans les
médias et la supplie de reprendre
contact avec elle est-ce que le travail
encore oui elle a fait un duo avec elle
pas besoin de travailler
je crois que ça je crois que ça fortune
fond comme neige au soleil ça peut
fondre
[Rires]
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle voulait comme ça
la dame elle casse tout en fait elle est
malheureuse
c'était quand même gravissime c'est à
dire que le père avait fait mettre des
caméras dans sa maison jusque dans les
toilettes quoi et dans la oui dans la
salle de bain dans sa chambre donc elle
n'avait aucune intimité c'était quand
même une situation vraiment horrible et
voilà c'est son père elle a été bête de
fois en fait
qu'il a complètement manipuler comme le
dit ils l'ont forcé à faire des concerts
alors qu'elle ne voulait pas elle était
coupée
[Musique]
j'arrive sur mime pour vous proposer
quelque chose de différent prolongé
l'expérience avec la Snake Army toutes
les semaines des échanges du partage des
avant-première des places à gagner des
accès backstage bref ici sur mime je
suis ici pour vous proposer une
expérience autour de ma musique non mais
je trouve ça fou qu'il y a un artiste
qui fait autant attention à son image
sponsorise et investissent dans une
plateforme comme linking qu'on le
veuille ou non dans l'inconscient
collectif c'est effectivement une
plateforme on paye des photos dénudées
clairement on prend des abonnements pour
voir des photos dénudées d'hommes ou de
femmes et en plus je crois qu'il
militent dans ses clips pour ne pas
avoir justement une donnée une image des
gardes de la femme de ne pas avoir de
fit trop sexy donc il a dû prendre
évidemment un énorme recherche alors
c'est pas forcément dégradant puisque
c'est un choix de personnes aujourd'hui
que ceux qui essayent de faire des
vidéos de la journée pour gonfler leur
followers pour après vendre des produits
etc là il y a pas de pub dessus voilà tu
t'abonnes tu t'abonnes pas tu mets des
contenus effectivement
de la pornographie c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les gens arrondissent leur foin de moi
voir gagne beaucoup d'argent en vendant
des photos de nues en oubliant que c'est
des traces qui restent plus tard et
c'est un moyen déplorable de gagner de
l'argent aujourd'hui je suis désolé et
en tous les cas ça marche ça marche très
bien pornographie il y a la prostitution
ça marche
de DJ Snake qui va le faire d'autre
chose
ça devient un peu mais c'est pour
redorer
c'est une info média il y a quelqu'un de
votre famille qui est sur mime vous le
saviez oh là là ça y est c'est ma mère
la femme mon père
à mes enfants
ma femme
la fiancée d'un de vos enfants
et oui vous savez qui ou pas bon je me
doute un peu là
alors je dis ça je l'aime beaucoup c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup adixia ah
sur mime
[Rires]
vraiment
allez-vous devoir vous doucher la peur
au ventre
tranquillement en train de te boucher là
hydrocution
on ferme notre gueule quoi couper l'eau
chaude à distance à partir du 15 octobre
enedis pourra donc couper l'alimentation
électrique des ballons d'eau chaude à
distance de certains clients pendant les
heures creuses l'eau ne sera plus
chauffée par dans le ballon d'eau chaude
pendant environ deux heures entre midi
et 14h donc c'est ce qu'il y a ce qu'il
faut retenir je veux pas être brusque je
veux simplement vous dire que
quand je veux pas être bon
non mais pour être très clair tout ce
qui a été dit jusqu'à présent
tout ça concerne je crois que c'est
important de le dire ça concerne les
personnes les gens qui ont un cumulus
pour chauffer l'eau qui marche à
l'électricité certaines ne marchent pas
à l'électricité là ça ne concerne que
cela et ces gens là en général ces
personnes là ont en contrat
d'électricité
qui s'appelle heure pleine heures
creuses je crois que tout le monde
connaît ça et ses heures creuses en
général elles sont le soir d'accord le
soir parce que l'électricité est moins
cher le soir et quelquefois elles sont
aussi entre midi et deux
méridienne d'accord et c'est le moment
où tout le monde compte en même temps
c'est en général entre midi et deux et
le soir quand on rentre entre à la
maison et donc on s'est dit les gens qui
chauffent l'eau entre midi et deux c'est
peut-être pas utile ça va nous être si
on évitait de chauffer l'eau entre midi
et deux ça va nous aider
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est que vous coupez les ballons de
choses chez les gens sans leur
consentement vous rentrez dans
l'intimité il faut vraiment que vous
compreniez une chose c'est que ce qui
est fait là c'est pour justement passer
l'hiver entre tranquille je suis
d'accord et le compteur Linky il a rien
au contraire
vous pouvez couper ou pas sans compteur
est-ce que vous allez le faire on ne
coupe pas on ne coupe pas on ne coupe
rien sans compteur Linky on aurait pu
faire exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire ne pas envoyer le signal
qui enclenche le chauffe-eau électrique
le chauffe-eau électrique mais moi je
vous pose la question toute simple s'il
y a pas de problème pourquoi vous coupez
les ballons d'eau chaude
[Rires]
quand vous dites ça moi je vous dis on
sait aujourd'hui que l'hiver va être
tendu ça vous ça veut dire quoi tendu
de coupure ah ben voilà ce risque de
coupure je risque de coupure on fait
tout nous enedis et les autres acteurs
du système électrique service public de
la distribution d'électricité pour
éviter qu'il y ait et ça fait partie des
choses assez faciles à mettre en œuvre
et qui vont avoir un fort impact le seul
fait de faire cela c'est l'équivalent
entre midi et deux d'accord de la
consommation d'une ville comme Paris
donc à partir de combien de à quelle
température c'est ça on va être en
situation tendue parce que les gens vont
tous à partir de combien de degrés 5
degrés 0 - 5000 les coupures c'est très
très difficile c'est à peu près certain
c'est que la température extérieure est
un des sujets importants un gros occupe
l'ensemble de la filière parce que si
l'hiver
en France aujourd'hui
voilà rien voilà a priori tout va bien
se passer effectivement si on a un hiver
sibérien je peux pas le dire mais
je crois qu'il est en dernier voilà
il y a des gens qui disent c'est à cause
de cet abruti de François Hollande
si vous n'avez pas fermé les centrales
nucléaires ça pose cette abruti de
François Hollande
position
de lui d'accord
très bien
c'est à cause de François Hollande mais
la pression des écolos la poussée à
effectivement fermé les centrales vous
parlez de la sobriété énergétique que
chacun doit respecter moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça mais dites-nous
concrètement énergétique ça veut dire 19
degrés pas plus tout l'hiver vous
maintenez ça ceci vous le donnez on ne
pourra pas chauffer plus au risque de
nos enfants et froid
sur les gestes du quotidien voilà si
chez vous c'est 19 degrés c'est une
bonne chose c'est ce qui est préconisé
mais si pour des raisons qui vous sont
propres vous préférez chauffer un peu
plus non je vais pas vous jeter la
plante
[Musique]
dimanche dernier en Normandie une
cliente d'un fast-food a fait une drôle
de découverte en dégustant son burger
voici ce que j'ai retrouvé après avoir
commandé dans votre restaurant coincé
entre la salade et le fromage un rongeur
identifié comme étant une souris cette
photo peut appétissante et immédiatement
fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
pourquoi je tombe sur ça j'ai failli
vomir alors pour tenter d'éteindre la
polémique l'enseigne à publier un
communiqué nous présentons toutes nos
excuses à la cliente qui nous a alerté
et plus largement à l'ensemble des
clients de nos restaurants alors à la
portée plainte Béatrice va nous le dire
mais ça en Amérique il fermait
des millions
j'ai une idée qui me vient en tête non
mais je mets là-bas un petit rat je le
mets dans mon burger ça marche là
quelqu'un ou 16000 frites dans un McDo
il a pris un million de dollars bien sûr
alors on parle de scandale en scandale
et une pizza on va pas citer les marques
les pizzas les œufs en chocolat il y a
tout et en fait en France vous avez 5800
agents au total pour tout contrôler
c'est impossible ça dépend de 3
ministères donc je vais employer un mot
qui est pas très joli c'est un bordel
total et chez nous ça passe
au bras de la santé des gens et il y a
des drames qui se passent là c'est
catastrophique mais c'est pas un drame
mais on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
en France je sais pas si vous souvenez
mais moi j'avais trouvé dans une canette
de soda très célèbre un morceau dedans
donc ça avait été identifié quand même
un morceau dedans non mais je vous ai
c'est un traumatisme alors évidemment
personne n'a été en balade donc dans un
premier temps on vous appelle le service
de consommateur ou des services clients
vous appelle on vous envoie un mail vous
défonir tout le code le code barre le
truc quand est-ce que vous l'avez acheté
la où et tout ça mais depuis j'ai eu un
appel j'ai rappelé et puis il y avait
plus rien en fait on vous laisse en fait
on vous laisse complètement dans la
nature et malgré tout il y a eu un truc
quand même très grave c'est un morceau
dent qui ne m'appartient pas qui
m'appartient pas à quelqu'un de la
famille qu'on a trouvé dans une canette
dans ce date ou pas non mais ça pose des
questions sur le tomber ça pose des
questions sur l'hygiène de lancer mais
ça peut aussi des questions sur la
manière dont on fait les burgers pardon
mais à quel moment le mec qui fait un
burger il voit pas qu'il est en train de
mettre un rat c'est pour ça que j'ai
posé la question dedans ce serait pas
d'accord et si c'est le cas ça dessert à
l'enseigne parce que ce serait un cas
isolé oui mais alors c'était justement
dans la salade c'était pas dans le sur
le bras
[Musique]
se rendait chez son fils lorsqu'il a été
violemment agressé dans ses escaliers
par une toxicoman transgenre de 24 ans
qui cherchait à s'acheter une dose de
crack et le pousse Jean-Baptiste au sol
lui donne plusieurs coups dans le bassin
il est actuellement entre la vie et la
mort les médecins estiment son espérance
de vie à 6 mois maximum il a perdu 10
kilos depuis son agression tu vas
rentrer dans mon immeuble aussi terrasse
du parc et sur la caméra de surveillance
on voit un individu qui le suit à 15
mètres et qu'il ouvre afin de ne pas de
se faire voir de mon père mon père à 92
ans il n'aurait pas vu de toute façon
bien sûr il rentre dans le patio
et là
l'individu le suit mon père se dirige
sur les escaliers dans mon rôle je suis
à l'étage
d'y mettre
et là au moment où il va grimper les
escaliers il reçoit un gros coup violent
à l'arrière du crâne et là je pense
qu'il a une grosse commotion cérébrale
on ne peut pas m'appeler mon père était
un ancien gendarme et malheureusement il
n'a pas voulu donner son argent et il a
commencé à se battre avec l'individu et
il a attrapé 92 ans l'individu par le
coup et il faut savoir que mon père
n'avait plus de force on tournait ne
serait-ce que la clé de mon appartement
c'était compliqué mais là avec
l'adrénaline et la réussi à le serrer
très fort
et et l'individu qui a 25 ans qui est un
homme non pas une femme il faut bien
alors justement oui c'est vrai parce que
c'est Gilles pour appeler
l'agresseur c'est un homme oui c'est un
homme avec alors on va le directe des
guillemets mais avec une attitude
féminine ce qui a d'ailleurs ce qui
aurait pu dérouter les enquêteurs mais
grâce aux caméras de vidéosurveillance
cette personne a été
identifiée et a pu être retrouvé bien
plus tard une semaine après par 450
policiers qui ont tout fait pour traquer
cette personne qu'ils l'ont retrouvé et
puis elle est aujourd'hui incarcérée en
détention heureusement cette personne
heureusement c'est pas tout à fait ça
les 450 personnes c'est Nunès qui se
déplace le préfet de Paris lorsqu'il
fait une descente d'accord il faut bien
comprendre que si on se déplace si le
préfet de Paris se déplace avec 450
personnes c'est que l'endroit est
terriblement dangereux exactement
c'est la bague qui a qui a interpellé
avant moi l'individu
je suis content que la BAC est fait son
travail et je suis content que cette
personne se retrouve en détention à
fleurir pour un bon moment à quel moment
vous apprenez ce qui vient de se passer
où
à peu près 7 à 8 minutes après
l'agression je sentais qu'il allait se
passer quelque chose vous lui disiez
d'aller arrêter de sortir tout seul
comme ça là je lui avais dit écoute papa
il pleut ne prend pas ton parapluie il
prend ta canne ce serait mieux ne sors
pas le climat n'est pas bon j'ai essayé
de l'intervenir mais c'est un homme qui
a toujours décidé décidé de tout et
surtout de sa vie je me dis qu'est-ce
qui serait passé si vous aviez croiser
l'agresseur quelques minutes après
j'aurais fait exactement ce qu'aurait
fait mon père il y a 5 ans je lui aurais
tordu le coup
et je serai sorti avec les pinces vous
avez dit parce que tout à l'heure vous
avez dit la BAC a fait son travail il a
trouvé avant moi
j'étais pas sûr du signalement donc on
était pas sûr
j'ai préféré laisser les autorités faire
est-ce que vous avez bien fait j'ai bien
fait votre père est dans quel état
aujourd'hui bien voilà il a perdu 10
kilos il faisait 55 kg il en fait que 45
en 20 jours il faut qu'il reste
immobilisé encore 20 jours
si dans 20 jours il fait 35 il sort de
bukenval
et vous vous connaissez la finalité
c'est très très compliqué les médecins
disent quoi
espérance de vie à 6 mois nuls
impossibilité de remarcher
moi j'ai pas encore
dans la section
Resort Angelina Jolie assure que Brad
Pitt a étranglé un de leurs enfants et à
frapper un autre au visage toute la
famille était alors à bord d'un vol
entre la France et les États-Unis
Angelina Jolie assure que Brad Pitt
l'aurait frappé à la tête secouer
pousser contre la paroi des toilettes et
quand l'un des enfants aurait voulu
défendre sa mère Brad Pitt s'en serait
pris à lui une partie des enfants
pleuraient explique Angelina Jolie
l'autre criait elle assure également que
Brad Pitt les aurait aspergé de bière et
de vin rouge
il y a eu aucune suite à l'époque ce qui
est quand même hallucinant il y avait ça
parce qu'elle voulait pas
mettre les enfants dans la sauce et là
où elle touche et elle fait mal c'est
qu'à la fin de l'histoire effectivement
il y a le fait qu'il aurait versé de la
bière et du vin et lui il vient de faire
une confession il y a quelques mois en
disant qu'un grand peigne il s'était
sorti de ses problèmes d'alcool terrible
en allant aux alcooliques anonymes etc
donc toute son histoire je ne sais pas
si c'est vrai mais c'est extrêmement
crédible parce qu'on lui c'est
dévastateur
des affaires qui sont déjà privés
sortent dans la presse
on en parle souvent c'est d'activités
on a envie de l'accabler on trouve ça
dégueulasse mais malgré tout on n'a pas
non plus tous les tenants et les
aboutissants ont substitue à la justice
et parfois moi je trouve qu'on rentre
dans la vie privée des gens dans leur
chambre à coucher dans leur intimité je
trouve que parfois on est un peu c'est
un peu gênant je trouve c'est un peu
compliqué
ça peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques sur sa carrière à lui alors
que on sait pas à quel point parce
qu'apparemment son histoire à elle sa
version a évolué beaucoup au fur et à
mesure des années donc bon il faut être
prudent
c'est Johnny Depp qui finalement s'en
est très bien sorti et c'est en dehors
qui à tout prix et donc je parierai que
dans ce cas précis il y avait un procès
les gens se mettrai du côté de Brad pit
comme ça oui mais ces histoires qui sont
intimes et vous avez raison c'est c'est
dingue on peut pas rentrer là-dedans on
peut pas savoir la vérité en fait nous
on a un tribunal médiatique on parle de
ça mais on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
vraiment en revanche c'est toujours dans
le cadre d'un procès donc chacun sort
tous les coups les coups possibles
jusqu'au dernier moment pour obtenir du
fric parce que de toute façon il s'aime
plus apparemment ils ont chacun leur vie
de leur côté et voilà est-ce que vous
êtes déjà balancé des choses dans la
presse qui vous concernait qui était
d'affaires privés à la table oui par
hasard quoi il faut être connu pour ça
c'est marrant j'ai posé une question
il y avait un vol de pigeon
ah bah si les feuilles de Noël
alors le monsieur mais oui
version old très belle ouais
non non non
elle était un peu cramée mais non c'est
pas cramé tu es magnifique elle était un
peu rosée 50 50
donc vous étiez vraiment avec la dame
non
je vais vous dire à quel point que on
voulait attaquer match mais il se trouve
que fade de Noé justement nous sommes
allés voir un avocat très célèbre qui
qui vit à Saint-Tropez non non on était
pas content du tout moi ça ça m'a posé
plein de problèmes elle elle s'en
foutait parce que bon bah oui elle est
cool si les américaines du manque un peu
gagner du fric
et donc
Bernard elle va répondre mais vous dites
une grosse bêtise parce que en Amérique
les procès pour atteindre la vie privée
c'est que dalle pour le coup
on est allé voir l'avocat de Dreyfus à
l'époque et il lui a dit écoutez si vous
attaquez en fait ce qu'il avait des
pluies dans l'article la feuille de Noé
c'est simplement que on révélé qu'elle
avait été drogué et alcoolique à une
époque de sa vie ça elle a pas supporté
voilà maintenant elle était splendide et
c'est une femme brillante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]